we are live sir
you guys
good evening everyone welcome to today's
meeting of the panel
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
officer on call is katie brewer
and her number is 577046
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted permission
to speak
to gain my permission to speak please
indicate on the chat and i will make a
note and call you when it's your turn
with everyone present please ensure that
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking emails
and ensure that you're in a quiet room
for the duration of the meeting
please note this meeting is being live
streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will subsequently be broadcast on the
internet please can i ask members of the
panel to confirm that they are present
at the meeting when i read out your name
councillor boyd
councillor coleman cook president chair
councillor curry present chair
councillor hopkinson
council hopkinson
councillor huxley president chair
councillor keane present chair
councillor pat moore present chair
councillor paul moore present chair
councillor linda piper
here chair thank you councillor rattigan
here chair councillor ropa
councillor roper
not can't see councillor ropa and
councillor scott i know he's not here
she's he sent his apologies
okay i've received the following request
to speak under 20.1
which is council of ghana on agenda item
7
are there any other members wishing to
speak under 20.1
all right hello councillor baker yes i'm
here um and just to let you know
um council of opa is trying to get in
he's having some problems so i've given
him um
the number of katie to give her a call
so hopefully you'll enjoy
it soon lovely thank you thank you
okay uh apologies for absence
uh the i've finally received the one
which is from councillor scott have
there been any others charles
apologies from councillor hopkinson
okay is he not joining us at all no i
don't think he will be tonight
okay all right thanks council curry
thank you
agenda item 2 declarations of interest
are there any declarations of interest
i can't see anyone indicating so i'll
take that as a no
agenda item three to approve the minutes
of the overview scrutiny panel meeting
held on the 18th of february 2021
a copy of which was attached to the
agenda pack could i have a proposal and
a seconder for those please
i'll propose that chair council coleman
cook thank you
seconder please i'll second that chair
councillor carrie thank you very much
unless i hear in the objection i'll take
those minutes as approved
gender item 4 minutes of an
extraordinary meeting
this is to approve the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of the ovu and
scrutiny panel held on the 17th of march
2021
copy of which was attached to the agenda
pack could i please have a proposal for
those please
i'll propose that uh chat camera thank
you
council curry second i'll second that
chair brilliant thank you very much
unless i hear any objection i will take
those as approved
thank you agenda item
5 domestic violence in thanet how kent
police are addressing the issue
i'd now like to welcome to the meeting
chief inspector rhiannon pepper
to make a presentation
thank you so much um thank you so much
for inviting me
so i was asked today following our last
meeting just talk a bit about
domestic violence and domestic abuse in
thanet
obviously it's something i am really
passionate about and when i took over in
november it was an area that
i thought really does need a lot of
scrutiny so for those of you that aren't
aware
we have a dedicated specialist officers
that deal with domestic abuse
i think that's really important in the
same way that we have it for hate crimes
and the same way that we have it for
rapes
to have that specialism and that
overview and it's to make sure
that we have the best person looking
into the offences because quite a lot of
time it is a one-on-one offense
and it's going to take a lot to get the
trust of the victim
so i'll briefly go through this and then
i'll talk about what i'm doing in thanet
so
domestic abuse recorded crime if you
have a look you can see we had
significant jump last year
11.8 jump in the recorded crime of
domestic abuse
again if you look at the charts you'll
see that september august september
is quite often a time that we see an
increase
there are other times that we know we'll
see an increase in domestic abuse so we
know over christmas we'll see an
increase
we know during the football we will see
an increase and we can plan for that
so and again we'll come more into what
our plans are and how we're dealing with
that
so the next slide is recorded arrests
and again you can see over the role in
three years
we've jumped up with our arrest rate and
that is really critical
because we have to show that we are
taking this seriously
and when it is proportionate and
necessary to rest we must be doing that
and that is
absolutely drilled into our offices
at all levels regardless of if their
first response if their cid
if they're the victim investigation team
which deals with domestic abuse
and the reason it's really important to
get those arrests is to get that
separation
to allow us time to go and speak to the
victim without the offender's presence
and again once i start talking about the
plans i'll explain again why that is so
critical for us to be able to do that
if we have a look at recorded charges
you'll see again we have seen a huge
jump in our recorded charges
um this year we have seen a real
significant
change towards our charge rate because
we are putting the investment in it
we're putting the
people in to do the investigations but
more importantly we are changing the
culture
and culture doesn't change quickly so
when i talk about changing the culture
look across all different forces to have
a look at domestic abuse how it's
been dealing with it um what is the best
way to get those prosecutions
and what was really clear is that when
we look at our sister force essex
the way they approached it was different
to the way we approached it in kent and
certainly within
it so from november we're starting it's
called the eight-point plan
but the main crux of this is that you
won't say
when you attend can i take a statement
when you attend
domestic abuse you will say i am here to
take a statement from you regarding what
has just happened
you're taking the ownership away from
the victim you are telling them
i am going to take this from you this is
really important i need to get the best
evidence
so that's the first one the second big
change
is that we now leave an officer with a
victim as i'm sure you're all aware with
the call command coming in
a lot of the time we go we arrest the
vic we arrest the offender
we take them back to custody and it's
probably two to three hours before you
go back
get back to the victim by which point a
lot of the time they've normalized
behavior the offender's gone they are
now in a safer place and they don't want
to engage with us
and so we've seen a real change by
leaving the officer there
getting that first evidential the
statements making sure the body warns on
so we can record all the injuries any
damage
getting that really good evidential
capture and that's made a massive change
as well
because it just shows we are taking this
importantly and
we're not allowing them to normalize
we're not allowing them once the
offender's gone to go
okay that's fine they're out the house i
don't need to worry about it
we're getting getting them and getting
the best evidence we can at the time
so the charge rate is on the up
if we have a look at the arrest rates
you'll see we're probably mid but you
see the jumps so
we are looking about 42 percent of all
domestic abuse
that we attend we arrest the ones that
we don't arrest there's a good reason
now there is so much scrutiny i've put
so much scrutiny in this
so in my morning meetings i will go
through every single domestic abuse that
we've attended in the last 24 hours
and i'll look what's been arrested what
hasn't been arrested and if there hasn't
been a rest
then must be a rationale so that i can
understand why there hasn't been an
arrest and sometimes
it is completely appropriate not to
arrest
but the times where i've looked through
and i don't think it's appropriate the
first thing i do is go back to the
inspector i will have a body-worn video
check
and i'll say what have they said to that
victim
why haven't we arrested why is there not
a statement
on a weekly meeting with my inspectors
we will look through domestic
abuse is part of the process and i'll
say talk me through
i want to know the body-worn video
checks that you as inspectors have done
on your staff to make sure that we are
going across there and treating those
victims correctly
making sure that when the officers are
attending they are taking it seriously
they are getting that buying and
confidence from those victims and we
have those weekly checks in place
again when we look at the charge rates
you'll see from last year 3.3
it has jumped to 6.4 that is a
significant
jump with charges it's still not as far
is still not as high as i want
and we are again continuing to make
progress
but it is putting that um
focus on domestic abuse which is
required
the next one is a da intimate breakdown
that's just explaining
when we say intimate that is intimate
partners or ex partners so you have
intimate and non-intimate
so none intimate might be a mother and a
son or two brothers
they will go into the non-intimate
intimate is partners or ex-partners
and again if you look through you'll see
the breakdown we will
generally have between 72 and 76
are going to be intimate d a that we
attend
and the last one and then i'll just talk
through a bit what we're doing
is repeat victims and this is the key
for me
because as you look down you can see
thanit disproportionately
has more six to ten reports over ten
reports we have more repeat victims in
thanet
and i want to know why that is is it
because we're not getting the confidence
of the victim at the
first one is it because we're not
getting the buy-in so again with the
specialist teams
and the local police officers and our
community
um safety unit we're trying to do visits
on those repeat victims it's
trying to build up their confidence one
officer continually
speaking with that victim to get them to
trust them to get them to actually
engage
and to try and break down that offending
pattern and there's other things
i've been looking at and implemented so
drug testing on arrival
underutilized so drug testing on arrival
is really important i think because
there are certain crimes that you can
automatically do it for but an inspector
and above
can do it for other offences so our
repeat offenders
the ones that we know have got a drug
problem we need to be drug tested on
arrival because then we can put a
positive obligation on them
to go and get help now the best case
scenario is that help works and we can
break that fending pattern
the worst case scenario is they don't go
for that help but actually by them not
engaging
we are building a better picture when we
take them to court to say
this is what we are trying to break this
pattern they are not engaging and we are
more likely to get
a successful outcome at court which is
really important
we've just had um alcohol testing as
well that's literally just come out
and again i'm talking with the
vulnerability teams around where we know
alcohol plays a big part in these
offending
we need to be putting alcohol tags on
the offenders we
really need to be breaking down over 10
reports
17 people that 17 people that we're
saying are constantly
suffering we need to be breaking this
down and getting better at it so i
talked quickly about the eight point
plan
i say the real change here is the
difference
that we've had with our local officers
our first responders and it's the why
when you ask somebody to do something
they will do it but you
must explain the why and actually
sitting down going to the briefings
explaining
that if you take this seriously if you
give them confidence in the first
instance if you get that best evidence
they will engage with us and we are
likely to get successful prosecution so
it's the retraining
and it has worked the culture has
changed and it's shown by our arrest
rate and it's shown by our charge rates
but there's still work to do as i say my
main focus at the moment is around those
repeat victims
is how we can engage with them how we
can look at
breaking that pattern that behavior
so something i'm really passionate about
we are heading in the right direction
there's a lot more that we need to do i
am acutely aware of that
but as a start in the last six months i
certainly think we've made some great
strides not only culturally but also
with our arrest rates and with our
charge rates into making a dent in this
thank you okay thank you very much for
that
members questions comments
come all right casper keen
thank you i mean it sounds really good
what you're doing
um i just wanted to go back to i think
it was the
the first slide and i think it was
arrests where
in the 19 to 20 year there were 130
in than it and 20 to 21 there were 278
now i know you've said about um you know
that you're doing this work so that
presumably would have increased that
anyway
but i just wondered if you thought there
was any other circumstances behind
such a big increase
i think because we've we've put the
focus and the vulnerability
investigation teams um has really put
the focus
on domestic abuse and as part of kent
police it has
it's an area that we need to improve on
and so by raising that understanding by
raising that awareness
and by explaining we we
take positive action and that is the
officers that are coming in they're
training
it is absolutely embedded in them that
we will take positive action
unless there is a a really discerning
reason why not
so the arrest rate i'm glad to see it
rising and i still like to see it rise a
little bit more
as i say i look through this every day
and there's sometimes ones where i go i
think we could have done more on that
one
so i think it is that change that we
will take positive action
unless there is a real reason why we're
not going to and then it has to be
evidenced
does that make sense yeah thank you
okay council curry
hello
increasing abuse um
i wonder whether the uh the increases
have been in particular areas
in fanny or has the increase been
um across the aisle thank you
i haven't got the break down here but i
haven't had a look through it and
i say it paying quite um keen ascension
to it since i've been here in november
it is very widespread so um
there might be certain demographic areas
that you think would have a higher
rate and that's just not the case
domestic abuse is everywhere
um through all our communities
regardless okay thank you
councillor boyd thank you chair
and thank you for your presentation it's
really good to see the chargements
and how we're doing quite well in
comparison to the rest of the county
um it was just more of a question around
is this type of domestic abuse more the
physical
side of things or how you see more of a
trending increase of
um coercive control emotional blackmail
those kind of things so i think there's
often a misconception that the musculus
is just
a physical assault so i just wondered
whether you have you seen cases because
obviously they
are probably quite more difficult to
prosecute and evidence i just wondered
if there's any work around that area of
domestic abuse
there is some work i don't have the data
with me now you are right we are seeing
more cursive
control and behavior um
the majority of these will have
a assault base to them be it's a consult
or hire but we are certainly seeing a
rise in
rehearsing control and value sorry easy
for me to say
um but again that that's to do with the
training again with the police officers
so they can pick it up
whereas before it wasn't being recorded
now officers are picking this up and
recording this and understanding this is
actually
as important and we need to deal with
this as robustly as we would do if
somebody had a physical injury
so yeah we are seeing that trend
increasing
well i can't see any other members at
the moment i've got a couple of
questions
the first is i think you said that the
charge rate
which is around about six percent you
were a bit disappointed with that
so a couple of questions around that
first is um what
do you think inhibits the charge rate
and is the implication of your
disappointment that
charging is a major factor in stopping
repeat behavior
okay i'll go with the first one
uh first question first now i think
a big inhibitor is the fear of
the repercussions the fear of the
offender
i think a big change is where we've sat
there and immediately
whilst it's fresh in their mind before
they have a chance to normalize and i
keep saying this
because that hour or two that we leave
with the offender
they calm down they normalize what has
happened so
actually getting that account straight
away
i think has made a big difference to the
way that we deal with it certainly
getting those statements
over 75 now of the calls we attend we
get a statement straight away and those
who don't get a statement
we look at and it is not through lack of
trying is that
they do not want to engage with us on
that occasion and the only thing we can
do there
is to then do a follow-up visit to try
and get them to engage at a later
time so i think the inhibitor
is the engagement with the officers
because of the fear
of what's going to happen next how's
this going to affect me
and it it is trying to break down that
cycle the second sorry if you throw the
second question again please
um well yeah the first one was what
inhibits the charge right and the second
one was whether you thought that
um charging was a major factor in
stopping repeat
offending i think there's a lot of
factors that need to be
explored around um stopping that
repeat offending i think charges do play
um a part especially in those um
serial offenders that are constantly
doing it be it with the same partner be
it with different partners i think
that does play a part but equally i
really do think
the help around the drug testing the
help around the alcohol the factors that
are causing them
to behave in that manner so the anger
management
i think they equally are as important um
taking those steps with the offender to
look at their behavior
and their patterning and how we can
break that down
thank you uh councillor boyd you wanted
to come back
yes thank you and it was just a another
thing i was watching
well half watching brookie telly um
yesterday morning and there was a piece
around vanessa produce
on it and i don't know where it was but
they were basically training up plumbers
and people at visit homes to be aware of
you know marks on the walls or doors
where you know they've been locked in a
bathroom or you know
handles and i just wondered whether the
potential for future work between
yourself and
possibly penny and the community and
some
engagement with our local um
housing service providers people who do
utilities
and just to kind of get more awareness
but i presume you're quite um
restricted to you know neighbours
hearing stuff
or as opposed to people actually going
to home so i just wondered whether that
was something an area you might
look into in the future i absolutely
love that idea i think that is
didn't see i think that is a cracking
idea um and it's
definitely something i'll take away and
then link in with because
you're right it is a lot of time it's
not the victim that phones us it's a
third party
but by having people raising the
awareness same way we did the child
sexual exploitation making sure the
taxis that the doormen
that licensees were aware raising that
awareness means we are more likely to
get those early indications and reports
of where domestic abuse is taking place
so actually i really love that idea i
think that is a really
good idea and one that we can go forward
with
brilliant okay uh councillor keane thank
you a
separate question um and that was just
where there's young children present
do the police automatically refer to
social services or is that a judgment
call
um no while the children are present we
automatically
will do also that they're aware and then
we also refer locally to schools as well
so that head teachers are aware that
we've attended because obviously the
impact on that child
the head teachers need to know what is
going on in their home life
because that could explain some of the
behavior in schools so we are very good
at making sure all our partners are kept
aware especially with children
voice of the child is really really key
um within kent police it's making sure
that we're listening and looking after
those children in those premises
that's great thank you okay
i can't see any other questions i've got
one last one i mean that domestic abuse
is
i think in most people's minds it is
associated with
female victims but we know that you know
there are male victims
um do you have any sort of figures for
the split in thanet
no i don't have the figures but you are
absolutely right there are male victims
um
i don't have the figures but again as i
say because i go through them
every morning i see the female to male
ratio is still
predominantly male against female but
there is certainly
a percentage of male victims and i think
sometimes it's harder for them
to make that call or have that
conversation
because of the way society looks at
domestic abuse
and again that's something we're trying
to really work with with
those males that have reported at
domestic abuse to make sure
that they've got the support they've got
the welfare um in place around them
okay thank you i hasten to add i wasn't
speaking
from experience
can i on behalf of the panel can i thank
you very much for the presentation
and and uh you're answering the
questions and uh i mean
it would be really good if you could be
a regular visitor i know there
we've covered a couple of areas i know
there's other areas of policing that
members would be interested in
but certainly you know perhaps in the in
12 months time a follow-up on
what you did last time and this time
would i think be very helpful if you'd
be prepared to do that
absolutely um always happy always happy
to see us what we're doing in thanet
so if there are areas you want me to
discuss
just let me know and again i'm quite
happy to come along and talk about them
brilliant thank you very much indeed
thank you bye-bye
[Music]
all right members moving on uh agenda
item six
memorials working party update i call
upon councillor stuart piper
chair of the memorial's working party to
give us an update
thank you chair good evening everybody
um there is a report attached
for this item which is similar to
[Music]
so he can make the final decision about
the application
in question historic england and the
secretary of state will apply the new
policy of
retain and explain meaning historic
statues will only be removed
in the most exceptional circumstances
i think the idea behind that chair is
probably self-explanatory it's designed
to stop knee-jerk reactions
uh such as we had uh not so long ago
uh with the memorial plaque in in
broadcast
the secretary goes on to say what has
stood for generations should be
considered thoughtfully
not removed on a whim any removal should
require planning permission
and local people should have a chance to
be properly consulted
our policy in law will be clear that we
believe in explaining and retaining
heritage
not tearing it down an important little
footnote at the bottom it says the new
rules will also apply
to unlisted historic plaques memorials
and monuments which will also require
planning permission
and historic england will be informed
chair i haven't i haven't had any
further explanation about looking
forward
to uh proposals to erect
new statues or plaques and monuments but
i would imagine the planning
permission clauses would still apply but
i'm sure that our proper officer will
put that in the final report when it's
prepared for you thank you very much i
commend that to
members thank you thank you um
members um the proposal um
is that uh we should if you like
uh so than a lot of the correct
terminologies and perhaps charles can
help me out
but we should sort of suspend
temporarily
um the activities of the working party
uh pending the national legislation
coming into force then you know
bringing it back into into action as
soon as that happens
but by doing that that will give us the
opportunity to
run a very short review of something
else in the meantime which i think would
be
very good use of members times uh
chairman
are you happy with that yes
yes indeed okay thank you
members uh comments please
okay i can't see anybody uh making it
wanting to make any comments so
therefore
uh can i propose from the chair that we
do as i've just outlined that
we sort of temporarily spent suspend
activity of this working party
pending national legislation being
introduced
which will allow the panel to authorize
another piece of work in the short term
does that find a seconder anywhere
i'll second that chair thank you
counselor coleman cook
um members is that agreed
agreed i can see lots of nodding i can't
see anybody objecting so
i'll take that as a degree thank you
members thank you very much
okay uh
agenda item seven planning enforcement
review
um this is a follow-up from the item
that we had in february
when the panel received a report from
ian livingston
um i'd like to open this discussion um
by hoping that we can this afternoon
agree a way forward the
the proposal in general that i would
make is that
we would in fact set up a small
working party maybe six seven members
um with the uh idea that they would
actually
inform the review of the enforcement
protocol the planning department are
looking at at the moment
and that perhaps a single
meeting of that uh working party might
be sufficient to come up with
suggestions that could be brought back
to this panel
uh for par onward pass into the
executive so
i'll ask you to think about that for a
minute while i bring in councillor ghana
who wishes to speak
under 20.1
thank you yeah thank you councillor
bayford
thank you and thank you members for
allowing me to speak at this meeting
i spoke at the last overview and
scrutiny meeting when planning
enforcement was discussed
asking for a scrutiny project to be
kicked off urgently
to conduct a proper open review into the
effectiveness of the informant
enforcement function within planning as
a whole
as a whole and to explore ways in which
it can be expanded and improved the main
reason i
think i thought and i still think this
is necessary
relates to the climate emergency we all
passed nearly two years ago now
a number of policy amendments have been
made to the local plan
to protect our natural environment and
enhance the biodiversity across the
district
many of these new policies will result
in planning applications being passed
with tougher climate emergency
biodiversity related conditions
it is vital that not only do we work
with developers
to make sure they understand what we
expect from them but also that we have
an
enforcement function that makes sure
what they do that they do what's
expected
as it stands i do not believe that we
have an enforcement function equipped to
be able to do this
as is noted in the report before you the
enforcement team works
in a reactive rather than proactive way
on the whole
once a planning application is passed
developers are left to get on with it
and enforcement officers only get
involved if they receive a complaint
from a member of the public as is also
noted in the report
tdc's enforcement team of two
is the smallest in the county a thorough
review is needed to identify ways in
which the process can be improved
so that the effective enforcement
function we need can be put in place
quickly the proposal for discussion this
evening
is i believe inadequate for two reasons
firstly the review team should be open
for contributions
from members of the public not just
concerned residents
but also representatives of the
development companies
who the enforcement team need to work
with
secondly if we really want this to be a
meaningful review
that will actually make a difference a
single meeting to review the planning
enforcement protocol with officers
isn't enough i would respectfully
suggest
that a team with a wider remit than that
is required
to include meeting with the planning
services manager
and planning enforcement officers to
understand and review current planning
enforcement protocols
and working practices and inviting
representatives of local developers and
concerned members of the public
to meet with the team to discuss current
working practices
and explore ideas to improve the process
before proposing changes to improve the
process
with agreement from all of those
involved thank you
thank you councillor ghana members any
any comments from anyone
okay councillor kane yeah i
just wanted to say that i agree with
what councilman ghana has said
i think a wider remit would be more
beneficial
i would also like to know more about
how other councils are dealing with this
because i do think partly because of our
small team
but that we do have particular problems
here
in our reactive approach
thank you okay a cancer roper
uh yes i would like to reiterate that
again that
support counselor gardener that having
just two enforcement officers is just
nowhere near enough to keep on top of
all the problems that that arise and i'd
seem to hear
countless of times when enforcement
officers just don't have the time to do
their job properly so it really does
need a
an in-depth review i feel thank you
okay um any other comments
um i've got um mr willis and mr porter
are present do either of you wish to
make any comment at this stage
and understand if you don't want to
um chairman would you mind if i make a
a comment check um
obviously it's for um members to
articulate and describe the terms of
reference
for for this action i think obviously
and i'm sure you will consider the of
the
any kind of outcomes from any review
we'll need to take we'll need to
inevitably
take into account the availability of
resources to support any
kind of outcomes that uh fall out of
that and also it's about managing
expectations if there's a suggestion
that
we engage directly with the public then
obviously
that also has to be managed in the sense
of understanding what resources would be
available to support any aspirations
that they may
they may be sharing and also i would
just raise the fact that
the time officer's time will need to
be taken into account in respect of
actually supporting
this review so we just need to be
mindful that we approach it in a
sensible manner because obviously
officers are already very busy but
appreciate the fact that members will
have
um a significant involvement in in doing
some of the
work or i'm assuming that members will
have an involvement in doing some of the
work
okay thank you um council huxley
thanks chair i'd just like to say i'd
like to be if you were going to set up a
subcommittee i'd like to be on that
the planning enforcement review isn't
just about new builds it's about
listed buildings in places like ramsgate
in the conservation areas so that's a
important part of it as well thanks
okay
okay um members i mean having listened
to councillor ghana
and one and other members obviously um i
think yeah the the valid points that
have been made
um the reason that um
we i was looking at a single meeting
review really was uh in recognition
of the scarcity of resource and in fact
taking advantage of the fact that we
were standing down the memorials working
party but
um you know that that clearly may be a
fairly temporary thing
um so what i'd like members to think
about i've got a couple of other people
to come in
in a minute um but um what i'd like
members to think about
is whether we could run with the idea
of a single
meeting for a review which would be
let's say six or seven members from this
committee
from this panel with uh appropriate
officers
um which has already been uh agreed in
principle
um by mr livingston he could support
that
but that the that review group
uh actually takes a wide view and as it
reports back to
to the panel if it does think that an
in-depth review
would be worthwhile it could think about
um
how that might operate and bring those
recommendations back which would enable
then
to set up a panel sorry
a committee a review committee um
with perhaps a wider remit than i was
thinking of
in the first instance now council curry
you've got your hand up
um you're muted counselor curry i think
dropped my hand and okay okay
from the top drop the top again yeah
uh thanks chair um yeah i just got going
to say i think
panel members do hear from residents
and uh we can take residents concerns
forward i think
this is what gives scrutiny its value um
having a close connection with
residents and i think a a panel
would hear from residents and take their
concerns forward
and i do think a single meeting um would
take this forward
quicker than something that took a very
long time
where we were talking to so many people
we've got bogged down
in uh in too many um proposals uh thank
you joe
thank you members are
there any other comments uh and if not
uh can i take it that there's
you know that we would be happy to start
off with this single meeting
quite a lot of nodding going on in that
case uh could i ask
for six or seven volunteers please
um ideally somebody from the planning at
least one person who's on the planning
committee would be useful
we've got councillor huxley
yes chair i'd be willing to be on that
council coleman sorry
i'd be willing to go on that chair
councillor linda piper
although i'm not on the planning
committee i have done the training i
know i mean
it's essential that we've got both you
know some planners and
some none yeah okay i would chair
okay council rat again yeah i would
share
council paul moore for more yeah
i'd be happy to share if you need one
more there
councillor curry okay i think uh
that's you know reasonable cross-section
um i think i think that would be quite
good
um can i just start i mean
councillor roper um we don't have a
green party representative on there i
wondered if you
might be interested
thank you for the offer but i think i'm
going to have to decline for personal
reasons
okay fair enough in which case um
we have a panel of uh or a
suggested review team of counselors
huxley coleman cook
council linda piper councilloratica and
councillor paul moore
councillor curry so is that agreed
members
yeah can i just ask uh chief executive
you you've heard the proposal um are you
comfortable with that
uh absolutely yeah thank you okay thank
you
members uh take that as agreed then
thank you very much
agenda item eight
right um impact of covid 19 on
businesses and communities in
oh sorry councillor kane sorry
didn't see you i just wanted to check on
my screen
counselor ghana looks like he's frozen
because i thought he might be interested
in being on the thing so
i didn't want him to miss out on his
opportunity if that was the case
uh the reason i didn't go to council of
ghana was that it was a panel
it was a group drawn from this panel in
the first
instance oh i see
yeah no i actually yeah okay that's fine
thank you i appreciate that hello
councillor king thank you very much
okay we obviously would but
okay um uh councillor ratigan
um i think the the choice uh
chair will be uh sorted out actually at
the meeting
okay um so
try again with agenda item 8
impact of covid19 on businesses and
communities in thanet
i'd now invite the chief executive to
share some ideas of how the panel
might approach this topic and after that
perhaps we could have a bit of a
discussion about
the way we might see the way forward so
maddie over to you thank you very much
chair thank you
uh members um i'm just going to take the
opportunity just to share with you
some things that um we have achieved uh
over the last year
in relation to our response to covid19
and then i've got
four options um that i'm going to
suggest
just to prompt a discussion uh it'll be
for you to decide which if any of those
or
a variation of those you want you want
to take forward
but i just thought it was only right
really um
for all of us in tdc just to recognize
uh what we
what we have been doing over the past
year and this is just some of the
main things obviously it's not
everything um and i think we all
accept that this year has been no longer
it's been unlike any
other year i mean obviously stanley is a
busy time at the best of places but i
think we'd all recognize that the
challenges the pandemic
uh has created this year were things
that we hadn't
uh anticipated however saying that
i think it's also fair to say that we
were actually actively
responding to the kovic 19 pandemic
before the first lockdown in march
and sometimes i think we forget about
that so
even before lockdown we had reviewed and
refreshed our business continuity plans
uh in light of the uh emerging uh
crisis of covid19 we'd already provided
capacity
for home working including training
sessions and crib sheets for
staff to enable them to access uh the
systems appropriately
we provided staff with regular updates
on the situation
including access to frequently asked
questions and we established an officer
group
including all senior management who met
regularly to review the situation
and make sure that we could respond to
take action
and then of course as we all know in
march or march the 23rd
came the national lockdown and which for
most industries
i guess this meant reduced work not
necessarily positive for them
but for us as a council and all of us as
a council that meant everyone's stepping
up and actually working harder
which in itself is quite a challenge
because i'm sure you appreciate um we're
not
we are quite lean as an organization
from a resource point of view
but within the first week we've managed
to reduce uh we've dealt with reducing
access to the offices
put in increased regimes and hand
sanitizers
established back office support for
those working from home such as scanning
and printing assistance
we closed off public spaces such as
playgrounds
we'd maintained our refuge collection
services
we'd allowed residents with parking
permits to parking council car parks
free of charge and suspended parking
charges for
nhs and social care workers we set up
and staffed a dedicated
seven day a week phone line to support
our vulnerable residents
to access services and supplies we
worked with partners to provide these
essential client
supplies because obviously we couldn't
do that solely ourselves so
we actually had to pull on our network
of community
and third sector organizations which
we'd already built
a very good relationship with we
contributed to a kent wide dedicated
business support line
and we provided temporary housing for
all those who were sleeping
rough at that time in addition to that
uh and as we move through the year we've
telephoned or visited over 6 000
extremely vulnerable residents we have
distributed 92 000 pounds worth of
support for the extremely vulnerable
through food provision
we've distributed 113 000 pounds in
support for those in fuel poverty
we have issued warnings and prohibited
notices to business who flouted the
restrictions
uh we've responded to the biggest influx
of visitors to the coast that we've seen
in a long time and you'll be aware of
that last summer
as part of our beach management uh plan
and again
obviously we're we've enhanced that for
this year
we increased the toilet cleaning regime
very importantly as a result of
maintaining
or trying to prevent outbreaks of kovid
19.
we were the first council in kent to
hold an online licensing subcommittee
we used innovative antibacterial
coatings on high touch points such as
parking machines
we temporarily closed roads to support
the reopening of high streets in july
we distributed discretionary test and
trace uh
support funding and we set up an
enforcement team specifically for covid
business enforcement and advice
we also provide a door knocking service
for track and trace and we'll continue
to do that as that's a requirement to
still
uh track uh any variations in covid19
we introduced covid wardens for the high
streets
we created the beach management plan
which i've already mentioned
uh we provided sites for two driving
testing facilities and kent's first
walk-in testing site
we worked with partners to ensure our
homeless population had acci
access to vaccines as a vulnerable group
and we've worked with local gps on how
to get vaccinations to the populations
where take-up was low
on business and on enforcement work
we've responded to 186 requests for
advice and that's since january 2021
this year
investigated at 89 complaints for
non-compliance
undertaken 597 compliance visits
given 57 informal notices and given 195
verbal warnings we have
four coveted waters patrolling the towns
and open
spaces seven days a week between the
hours of 10 and six
and so far we've spoken to 851
businesses
around guidance and compliance advice
and 1861
members of the general public i'm now
going
and i in addition to that we have also
of course been engaged in the kent
wide response i've chaired the
vulnerable people community cell
and other officers have been key players
in the enforcement environment and
finance sales
as well as as well as various other
tasks and finish groups
and of course we have engaged quite
significantly over the period
in our tactical command group meetings
and the strategic command group meetings
as i'm sure some of you appreciate they
were at one point happening on a daily
basis
including over christmas uh on that
point i am now just going to hand over
to tim willis who's just going to take
us through the grants
that he's been he and his team have been
busy working on overshoot him
thank you madeline thank you chair um
lots of numbers
so i'm going to try and keep this to as
few numbers as possible
um business grants and business rate
relief we did start the uh the lockdown
last year with business rates relief and
we administered 22 million pounds worth
of rates relief
in the retail hospitality and leisure
sector
and then since then there's been sort of
three tranches of business grants
we started off last spring and summer
there's been two types
sort of mandatory and discretionary and
the first trunks we distributed
34 million pounds worth of grants
which included 1.6 million of
discretionary grants
then during the lockdowns that started
in november there were a series of
payments
another two grant schemes and we've just
distributed about 20 million pounds 4
million pounds of which was
was discretionary that was called the
args
um and now we have um restart grants
which um were launched on the 9th of
april
which we estimate will be worth about 11
million and
we have another discretionary scheme
which we launched on the 12th of april
which we were expecting 750 000 for that
i think one of the key factors in in
relation to the
resourcing that's been needed in terms
of administration
for the council is that we've
administered all of the discretionary
schemes
and just the um the winter discretionary
scheme alone
has generated five and a half thousand
emails
to businesses and from businesses over
the last three months
for the for the arg team all of whom are
volunteers and do the work on top of
their day jobs
um so overall we've we've we've paid out
about 70 million pounds of grants to
businesses over the last year or so
and 22 million pounds of rate relief um
that's all i wanted to say
thank you chad right thank you can i
should i present the four options uh i'm
just going to if i may share just going
to
uh present those just so that you've got
them in front of you if that's okay
there's nothing
sophisticated about them they're just my
thoughts just
to prompt a bit of discussion for you
okay i hope
you can see those um so we've got four
options there option one
is that we provide overview and scrutiny
with the presentation
on our response to covet uh 19 between
march 2020 and march
2021 so a year or option two overview
and scrutiny could undertake
how did we do review of tdc's initial
response to the first lockdown
march 2020 to june 2020 including
continuation of service delivery and our
engagement with kent resilience form as
part of the emergency response
option three that you review how we've
managed the government's covered funding
streams including
as tim's obviously just shared business
grants
safely opening the high streets and the
clinically extreme
extremely vulnerable funds there are
some other
additional ancillary funds that we could
include in that as well
option four that you review our
community response during the pandemics
specifically the work of the community
hub
and our engagement with voluntary sector
okay thank you for that for four good
options
uh members comments please
you've stunned everybody into silence
maddie
well i mean you could we could start
with a a
a a presentation to you um
on you know if in a bit which gives a
bit more detail on the things that we've
sort of highlighted
um this evening and then take it from
there it's
um up to you really how you want to take
that forward
okay um
check go for option four
please four yeah because
we've had quite um in-depth um
information about the business grants
um and and i'd be interested to see
what our community thinks about how
the council responded to the covid
restrictions
and and all that they have done thank
you
okay yeah i i'd agree with that i quite
quite like that also quite like option
two which isn't very helpful i know
but um but we have a a proposal for
option
four does that find uh
second or anywhere
i'd second that chair council
pastor paul moore okay um
okay so if we go for option four
um i suppose what we'd be looking for
is to bring to future meeting perhaps
the next meeting of overview and
scrutiny
uh some proposals of of how we might go
about that
and what would be the most effective
structure that
would you be able to organize that chief
executive yeah absolutely happy to do
that i'll put some terms of reference
together and some structure around that
and a proposal for how you might be
involved in that because i think
it's important that and clearly that's
what this is about making sure that
you're involved in that review
and uh depending on how that goes
there's no reason why we can't revisit
revisit option two once we've done
option four if you if you still want to
do that
fine okay members does that does that
find agreement
again i can't see any objections i can
see some nodding so
uh we'll bring back to the next meeting
of ovian scrutiny some proposals for how
we go about
uh instituting option four so that
agreed
all right thank you very much members um
thank you uh tim and maddie for the
contributions there
gender item 9 review of isp work program
members are invited to comment on the
work program
and if there are no comments members are
requested to note the report
is that noted thank you
the gender item 10 forward plan and
exempt camp
cabinet report list for period 10th of
march to
31st of august 2021 unless there's
something from the plan that the panel
would wish to consider
members are asked to note the report
okay that's julie noted members officers
thank you very much for your time
i wish you good evening thank you very
much
bye